Thank You Ginger Rogers congratulations
Fred
our next award I insist on giving myself
it should come under the heading of a
Pioneer Award but the ageless vitality
of the man to whom it's been voted is so
extraordinary none of us can think of
him as a pioneer he was though in space
he was the man who wired his New York
bosses but the best place to make
pictures in the West was an unknown
village near Los Angeles called
Hollywood
it's an incredible that a man of his
youth should have made the first
American moving pictures of stirring
beauty how many of you were old enough
to remember Mary Arosa and Joan the
woman they were landmarks the award
might have been voted to him on an
entirely different basis as Miss as mr.
show business himself for 37 years he is
understood best how to amuse and thrill
and entertain the American public his
achievements range from dramatizing the
ten commandments to discovering the man
who became Hopalong Cassidy it's a
beautiful thing never to have been a
bore and he has turned out thunderously
entertaining pictures from the [ __ ] Man
to samson and delilah
for 37 triumphant years this Oscar goes
to Cecil B DeMille
it should be the case with a young
energetic producer mr. DeMille is out of
town preparing a picture I called him
this morning and told him he had been
voted and Oscar and who was to accept it
his first comment was could the Academy
vote mrs. DeMille a pair of wings
this is mrs. DeMille
okay thank you very much and I'm sure
I'm very sorry that mr. DeMille is here
not here and I know that he would be
very sorry and very appreciative thank
you
as no Thalberg award was voted this year
i can i can now turn you back to Paul
Douglas